the russian invasion will of course be a
big issue for president biden tonight in
the state of the union address but a new
cbs news poll just out this morning
finds that americans also have other
issues on their minds and the poll also
shows that the president's overall
approval rating is at 44
a number that is 18 points lower than
just a year ago driven down in part by
growing concerns over the economy
and inflation that'll keep us at the
white house for us ed good morning what
do we think the president's going to do
to try to get these numbers up well good
morning tony the
speech he's giving tonight is certainly
not the one he was expecting to give
even just a few weeks ago but the
russian invasion has forced a rewrite
and that same poll shows most americans
want to hear about the president's
foreign policy and how a war in europe
could affect people here at home
as russian attacks intensify in ukraine
new cbs news polling shows a majority of
americans supporting u.s actions in
response to russia but they're also
concerned about a wider war
president biden is downplaying russian
president vladimir putin's decision to
put his nuclear forces on alert mr
president should americans be worried
about nuclear war no and the isolation
of russia continues
days after the u.s and dozens of other
countries imposed historic sanctions
standard and poor's downgraded russia's
credit rating to junk status and russian
airlines are grounded by airspace
restrictions across europe but ukrainian
officials visiting washington are
pushing for more they will probably
erase kiev park even the other cities
from the map they're pleading with the
us to impose a no-fly zone over ukraine
we need to protect the sky because they
are using the sky to shoot us but the
white house says that's unlikely a
no-fly zone would require implementation
it would require deploying u.s military
to enforce
which would be a direct conflict
potentially direct conflict and
potentially war with russia which is
something we are not planning to be a
part of on capitol hill lawmakers are
now focused on sending more weapons and
humanitarian aid to ukraine vladimir
putin will lose this battle he will lose
this war he will be
a pariah amongst not only nato and
america but amongst all civilized
nations around the world the economic
impacts on energy and food prices as a
result of this conflict are not just
going to go away in two three or four
weeks this is going to be a multi-year
challenge and the crisis is set to
dominate the president's first formal
state of the union address tonight and
that's what most americans want to hear
but other top concerns include the
economy inflation and the pandemic
so on those issues of the economy and
inflation let me show you two more
numbers from our new cbs news poll out
this morning 62 percent of americans
disapprove of mr mr biden's handling of
the economy and when it comes to
inflation the response is even bleaker
70 percent disapprove of his response to
the recent spike in prices so to ease
that economic pain tonight he's expected
to call on congress to help lower the
price of things for americans by calling
for a new child tax credit expanding
health care options and raising the
federal minimum wage to 15 an hour nate
and we are looking forward to what he's
going to say tonight ed thank you